in 2017 tom hall and spider-man swung
his way into our hearts
and so did the latest mj zendaya yeah
from mary jane to michelle jones there's
a long legacy to live up to but we think
zendaya takes the crown for the best
mj in spider-man history thank you
mj is a love interest for spidey like
we've never seen before
and with three different live-action
versions of the wall crawler
we've seen plenty somehow despite
spider-man being so frequently adapted
and rebooted
michelle jones ended up being a fresh
and innovative character
i'm messing with you let us know if you
agree with us by the end of the video
or tell us why you feel differently in
the comments you ready
yeah you're gonna love this
in a way the different spider-man
franchises provide an interesting lens
through which we can see the evolution
of women's roles in superhero movies
over the past couple of decades
we've come a long way since kristen
dunst mary jane in the original sam
raimi trilogy
while 2002 may not seem like that long
ago women's roles in superhero movies
and
action movies in general have changed so
much for the better that raymie's mj
doesn't really hold up to modern
standards for a female character
this mj may have the iconic kiss but
apart from that
and the fact that dunst rocks that red
hair there's not much else going for
this particular version of mary jane
constantly kidnapped and somehow always
finding herself in the bad guy's line of
fire
a good chunk of dunce dialogue is just
screaming for help
when she isn't in danger for the sake of
the plot her only job is to have a
complicated love life
her on-again off-again relationship with
peter parker and multiple love triangles
have her going in circles leaving little
room for her to grow as a character
while it's nice to see that mary jane
doesn't spend her time apart from peter
pining for him
instead she does her best to try and
move on nearly all of her
characterization is defined by her
relationships with men
to be fair there were efforts made to
add depth to this version of mary jane
it's just that they all fell short there
was some focus placed on her career as a
model and hopeful stage actress but it
was mostly used to contextualize peter's
feelings
adding in a backstory of her coming from
a broken home doesn't do much to flesh
out her personality
hardly ever coming into play and only
serving to play further into her role as
a helpless victim for spidey to save we
can hardly blame dunst
who gave the best performance she could
and to her credit
added charm to the character but she was
working with a script that gave her very
little to work with
the sam raimi trilogy certainly didn't
do justice to the mary jane fans who
fell in love with her in the original
comics
that's what made gwen stacy from the
amazing spider-man movies such a breath
of fresh air
well i guess i don't need to tell you
what happens if you forget that
as the romantic lead she fulfills the
same role as mj
so we decided to include her as an
honorable mention plus in the comics
she was peter's girl long before mary
jane entered his life played by emma
stone
this leading lady was a huge step in the
right direction and helped pave the way
for zendaya's mj
gwen is an assertive science genius who
plays an active role in both amazing
spider-man movies
providing the scientific solutions to
spider-man's problems
and fending for herself in the face of
danger heroic in her own right
she selflessly remains in a dangerous
area to help evacuate other civilians
proving herself to be a quick thinker
and resourceful she uses her scientific
know-how to ambush the lizard from her
hiding place with an improvised
flamethrower
despite her young age and the challenges
women face in the field of science
gwen is highly motivated and ambitious
she worked as an intern at oscorp and
graduated high school as class
valedictorian
she is even a candidate for a
scholarship to the prestigious
university of oxford
oxford i didn't know yeah stone brought
a confident yet approachable heir to the
character with her performance
full of personality from moment to
moment with an endearing quality to her
oh
she has great chemistry with andrew
garfield's peter parker
making for a downright adorable movie
couple the two seem to have a genuine
spark between them
creating an on-screen romance we loved
watching unfold
their relationship isn't always smooth
sailing but despite
all of their ups and downs gwen is there
when peter needs her most
coming to his aid when he is in over his
head and refusing to sit on the
sidelines
sadly gwen's proactive role is what
leads to her downfall
leaving spidey heartbroken in the
process this decision faced criticism as
an example of fridging a practice of
injuring or killing female characters
solely for the development or motivation
of a male character
while gwen's death was a story point
lifted directly from the original comics
some argue the modern retelling could
have and should have deviated from the
dated source material
as many felt that gwen was one of the
strong points of the amazing spider-man
reboot
comic books have had a bad reputation
for fridging given the long history of
comics
there are many once traditional details
in the canon that have since been phased
out due to changing tastes and societal
values
but fridging has remained consistent
enough to see several examples across
the cinematic adaptations of marvel
properties
although this was far from the only
problems that critics and audiences had
with the amazing spider-man 2
the film might have benefited from
defying this particular expectation
set by the source material
perhaps the decision to write an
entirely new character to play the love
interest of tom holland's peter parker
was born of a desire to break away from
the decades-old comic book story lines
michelle jones nicknamed mj is less of a
reimagining of mary
jane than her own entirely new character
marvel studios president kevin feige
expressed that the decision to give her
the initials mj was merely an homage to
spider-man's most iconic sweetheart
feige was sure to emphasize that
michelle jones is not mary jane with a
twist
making her the first on-screen romance
for peter that didn't come from the
comic books
even liz toombs in homecoming was based
on liz allen from the comics
liz was also played by a woman of color
laura harrier
despite her comic book counterpart being
a blonde white woman
regardless this casting decision didn't
come without its share of confusion
and controversy with some fans taking to
twitter in response to rumors before the
film's release that zendaya would be
playing mary jane
objecting to a traditionally white
redhead character being played by a
woman of color
this was so early on in production that
before he had even been given the chance
to read the script
director james gunn responded to the
controversy on his facebook page saying
if we're going to continue to make
movies based on the almost all white
heroes and supporting characters from
the comics of the last century
we're going to have to get used to them
being more reflective of our diverse
present world
since then the response to zendaya's mj
has been mostly positive
with critics and audiences praising the
casting decision as a much needed
injection of diversity in the mcu
while providing a fuller more
well-rounded character for peter
parker's high school sweetheart
zendaya threw herself into the role with
enthusiasm even taking inspiration from
the classic comic book icon and dyeing
her hair
red she showed off her new do by posting
a picture on her instagram with the
caption
faceit tiger a reference to mary jane's
first appearance in the comics
this was a move that showed zendaya
truly has an appreciation for the source
material
she stated in an interview with good
morning america that she went to see
spider-man on her first date when she
was just 16 and was obsessed with it
immediately
it's always a plus to see actors that
feel a personal connection with their
projects
zendaya's dedication is evident in her
performance and it's easy to tell that
she has fun with the role
her mj is the closest to a real high
schooler love interest in a spider-man
movie that there has ever been
mj feels like a truly modern update
she's sarcastic and aloof
keeping her guard up when it comes to
her feelings just like a real teenager
so where do you want to go who cares
rather than retreading the tired trope
of the hopeless nerd pining after the
unattainable popular girl
mj is already in peter's social circle
as a highly intellectual smart-mouthed
outcast
a choice that makes her far more
relatable and a bit of a rebel
beneath her cool as ice exterior she is
still a quirky young woman struggling
with ego and insecurity like any other
teen
weird although she is a member of the
academic decathlon team alongside peter
mj is more than just book smart she is
clever
and observant suspecting early on that
peter parker is spider-man's secret
identity
she's so invested in proving her theory
that it's her top priority
as opposed to peter who spent the
entirety of far from home up to that
point
obsessing over his plans to confess his
feelings to her
once her suspicions are confirmed she is
supportive
you're going to need this helping
spider-man's investigation and letting
down her walls enough to let peter into
her life as
more than a friend what really sells the
relationship is zendaya
and holland's performances giving the
couple a realistically awkward but sweet
dynamic that feels natural and true to
real life high school romances
make no mistake zendaya's mj is no shy
helpless bookworm
when she finds herself in danger she
doesn't hesitate to defend herself
taking more charge of the situation than
her teacher the actual adult in the room
thanks to her resourcefulness and her
will to take action she and the other
students managed to hold off the
villain's drones long enough to survive
until spider-man is able to deactivate
them
mj finds a good balance between throwing
herself into danger
and being a mere cheerleader on the
sidelines playing a supportive role that
lets her add to the story as an active
participant
hopefully we can look forward to her
inquisitive nature and investigative
skills
helping out peter in future installments
giving her a similar role to peter's
best friend and guy in the chair
ned judging from the ending of far from
home
spidey's certainly going to need all the
help he can get
what really sets michelle apart from the
previous is that unlike mary jane
the beautiful girl next door who becomes
a model and gwen stacy
a super genius science whiz that
graduates top of her class
mj is relatively normal she's gifted
she's smart
but she isn't held to the sky high
standards set by the previous ladies
younger women in the audience will more
easily identify with a girl like
michelle
rather than comparing themselves to a
super model or a super genius
and feeling like they come up short
quirks and all
we choose zendaya's mj as the best
romantic lead in spider-man history
she's more than a pretty face actively
contributes to the plot
and feels the most real out of any of
the girls that have caught spider-man's
eye
what other changes were made in the
latest iteration of spider-man that you
think work well
or maybe there are new elements that you
think don't work at all
either way tell us in the comments be
sure to let us know if you want more
spider-man related videos in the future
hit that like button and subscribe